Swine dirty talk. A motherly girlfriend
in more ways than one. Unwelcome visitors
and selfies. These moments in
Frasier will make you say "yikes!"
"God, I could throw you down on this
floor right now and – hi! Hello."
A little over halfway through the final season
of "Frasier," Laurie Metcalf becomes the third
actress to play Nanette Guzman — Frasier's
ex-wife with whom he shares a potent sexual
chemistry. Nanette is best known as the popular
children's TV and stage personality Nanny G,
and when she shows up in "Caught in the Act,"
Roz forces a reunion between her and Frasier
in hopes of scoring tickets to Nanette's
performance for her daughter. Nanette is
desperate for a tryst with Frasier,
but we soon learn she's remarried.
"Donald here does, well, just about
everything for me. He's my manager, producer,
songwriter, publicist…Husband.
I was getting there."
On the night of her Nanny G performance,
Frasier goes backstage to tell her nothing
can happen between them. Nanette manages to
seduce Frasier regardless, and they throw each
other on a bed and begin to take things too far
... when the bed begins lifting off the ground.
It turns out this is the
opening of Nanny G's show,
when she's supposed to emerge from
the bed to sing the first number. At
first Frasier — buck naked at this point —
hides under the covers while Nanette sings.
Desperately, she shoves a costume under
the blankets that includes a baby bonnet
and a diaper. Frasier emerges from the bed,
wearing the ridiculous and disturbing outfit,
and Nanny G announces in surprise that she has
a new baby brother. Frasier tries to dance his
way off the stage, only to find Nanette's
angry husband waiting for him in the wings.
The Season 7 premiere, "Momma Mia," introduces us
to a new love interest, and at first, Frasier is
blind to the reason for her allure. While waiting
for a blind date at Cafe Nervosa, Frasier is
smitten with the woman we soon learn is children's
author Mia Preston, played by Rita Wilson.
In spite of an awkward and funny mix-up
at the coffee shop, Frasier and Mia hit it
off. There's no immediately apparent reason
to feel at all strange about the pairing,
until Mia meets Niles, who reveals to
Daphne that Frasier's new girlfriend is
the spitting image of their dead mother.
"Does she remind you of anyone? Oh,
you noticed that, too? Are you kidding? From the
minute I laid eyes on her. Even I can see it."
When Mia joins the family for a weekend in a
cottage, Marty agrees with Niles' observation,
and it makes things even weirder when
Mia acts motherly toward Frasier,
like offering to cut up his food for him.
Marty and Niles argue about whether or not
to say something to Frasier, but
when they watch a home movie that
includes Frasier's actual mom and he sees the
resemblance for himself, they don't need to.
Unfortunately, once Frasier sees the similarities,
it ends things between him and Mia. But it isn't
the end of Rita Wilson's time on "Frasier."
Wilson reprises the role of Frasier's actual
mother as part of a dream sequence in
Season 9's "Don Juan in Hell: Part 2."
Frasier isn't known for an
affinity for physical labor,
and in Season 10's "Some Assembly
Required," we discover an interesting
and disturbing reason why he should
probably stay away from such endeavors.
Frasier's co-workers at the station sign
him up for a program that builds houses
for low-income families. When the house is
complete, Frasier makes a speech as if he
were singularly responsible for the entire
house's construction, however his anecdotes
reveal he was only allowed to perform the
most limited of tasks, like stirring paint.
Regardless, Frasier develops a strange
attachment to the house and its new
family. He visits them just after they move
in and offers some free decorating tips.
"Frasier, hi. What a surprise.
Honey, guess who's here again."
The family is grateful at first, but
their gratitude grows sour as Frasier
not only won't stop dropping in uninvited
but continues to criticize their decorating
choices. He gives them tons of unasked
for accessories and acts betrayed when he
discovers they've put up a cow-shaped mailbox
rather than the one he bought them as a gift.
The new homeowners are forced to eventually
shove him out of their front door so that he'll
get the message. He does eventually
come to his senses and apologize,
and they reward him with a tour
of their fully decorated home.
Frasier is barely able to contain shrieks of
horror when he discovers the new black-and-white
cow theme of the interior, along with a freshly
painted bathroom that Frasier describes with,
"Wow, that's purple!"
In the final season of "Frasier,"
Julia Sweeney guest stars as Ann,
an insurance claims adjuster that
Roz sets up with Frasier. In "The
Placeholder," Roz knows things won't
work out between Ann and Frasier,
but she acts as matchmaker anyway to keep
Frasier's dating skills from wasting away.
Frasier wants no part of it at first,
but after an awkward night of being
the fifth wheel at a couples' dinner
and another night of cat-sitting that
makes him feel like an old maid,
he's willing to take the plunge.
Along with just the cringey notion
of dating someone as a placeholder,
Frasier's treatment of Ann doesn't make
him appear to be much of a gentleman. He is
clearly annoyed by Ann right away and isn't
looking forward to the rest of the evening.
When Ann heads to the restroom,
Frasier's co-worker, Kenny,
shows up with his lovely cousin,
Liz Wright — making her, literally,
"Miss Right." Frasier lies to them, saying
his dinner with Ann is just business,
and he spends the rest of the date trying to
ditch Ann so he can take his shot with Liz.
Of course, both Ann and Liz eventually figure
out what Frasier's up to, and he gets the public
shaming he deserves, though absurdly, Ann still
wants to meet him for coffee the next morning.
"You're just another selfish, dishonest
creep. You're right. I don't know what to say.
Well, maybe you can come up with
something before we have coffee tomorrow."
Frasier uses the line "I'm listening" when he
takes calls on his radio show. This episode from
Season 11 uses the line for its title, and sees
the good doctor eavesdrop at all the wrong times.
"Now I know why you're always saying,
"I'm listening." Because you always are."
Early in the episode, he accidentally
overhears Wendie Malick's Ronee — Marty's
new love interest — making a date
with another man on the phone. Later,
he winds up hiding in the kitchen when
Marty confronts Ronee about the date.
But without a doubt, the most cringey
snooping comes at the end of the
episode. Frasier is searching Ronee's car for
a lost money clip when she and Marty show up,
appearing to be on the brink of breaking
up. Frasier hides in the back seat and
listens to them make up and, eventually,
agree to date each other exclusively.
For a second, it looks like Frasier
will get a chance to escape when the
couple starts to head upstairs, but
then Ronee has a "better idea" about
driving to a secluded beach so she
and Marty can "steam up the windows."
Frasier throws himself down on the back
seat before either of them can spot him and,
we can only assume, unwillingly goes along
for the ride where he's likely forced to
know much more about his father's
love life than he ever wanted to.
As a show reaches its final season, it's only
natural for ideas to run dry. Such is the case
with "Frasier" Season 11. In Episode 17, "Coots
and Ladders," Frasier recounts his bad day in a
series of flashbacks while Niles anticipates
a crime Frasier has admitted to committing.
Although it's not exactly the most entertaining
plotline of the series, one moment in particular
will make you cringe. After a kleptomaniac calls
into his radio show and a beautiful woman turns
down his advances, Frasier finds himself helping
his elderly neighbor change her lightbulb.
When he learns the 83-year-old woman is still
successfully dating, Frasier's bitterness comes
to a boiling point, and he pockets one of
the woman's trinkets. Frasier's over-the-top
reaction is played for laughs as he and Niles
try to return the item. But it's not as funny
when you remember he's a grown, educated
man taking advantage of a trusting elder.
The cringiest part of all arrives when
Frasier and Niles stumble into the woman's
surprise birthday party and have to talk
their way out of Frasier's theft. They go
through many hoops trying to return the
item without anyone noticing. Thankfully,
they succeed — but we're left cringing
at the two foolish Crane brothers.
Frasier has a chaotic dating life. The snooty,
middle-aged psychiatrist can't seem to hold
down a woman for the life of him. Although
he doesn't have much luck with the ladies,
he still has not given up hope. But
sometimes, that doesn't feel like a virtue:
Many of Frasier's most cringe-worthy
moments are the result of him trying
to impress women. We'll give him an
A for his mostly respectful effort,
but we will not forgive the cringey dirty talk
between him and his new girlfriend, Madeline.
In Season 2's "Adventures in Paradise: Part
1," Frasier and Madeline take a romantic trip
to Bora Bora. He soon finds out they have
booked a room next to his ex-wife and her
new lover, which is awful enough on its own. But
surprisingly, it doesn’t come close to the moment
the couple hops in bed together and indulges in
the worst kind of foreplay. Frasier exclaims,
"I'm sweating like the pig
that knows he's dinner."
When Madeline leaves to freshen
up, Frasier makes everything worse,
"I'll be right back. Oink."
Madeline might be into the strange pig reference,
but for everyone else, it's
become a suppressed nightmare.
We love the Crane brothers for their
intellectual interests and expensive
tastes,when they're not putting others down
because of them, anyway. But when the two get
tickets to see the hottest play in town,
their excitement quickly fades after they
realize the tickets were for an earlier time,
forcing them to scrounge at the last minute.
They'll do whatever it takes to maintain
their high-class social standing — except
wait in the cancellation line
like a couple of peasants.
"The last thing I need is to have
someone see us loitering outside
here like gutter riffraff pathetically
scrounging for last-minute tickets."
Their superiority complexes are often charming,
but in this case, they lean towards cringe.
It's uncomfortable to watch Frasier and Niles
desperately try to conceal their lack of prestige.
Everyone wants to impress their
friends every once in a while,
but it's in the Crane brothers' nature to take
things too far. In reality, it's likely their
friends and the rest of high society could not
care less about Frasier and Niles' ticket status.
Frasier and Niles don't have the
best relationship with their father,
Martin. Their combative dynamic is
first introduced in the pilot episode,
when Frasier agrees to let his
injured father move in with him.
Although they learn to make it work, their
distinctly oppositional personalities
constantly clash. This remains true
in Season 1's "Dinner at Eight."
After trying to take Martin to a fancy
restaurant that's obviously out of his
comfort zone, Martin treats his boys to
his own favorite restaurant. Frasier and
Niles can't help but rag on the place for
its lower-class status. They're outright
offended by the casual waitstaff
and steak-and-potato offerings.
Despite Martin's attempts to humble
his sons, they don't let up on their
not-so-subtle insults. Martin is forced to
leave the situation. Instead of apologizing,
Frasier and Niles make it their mission to
finish their food in their father's honor.
They even go as far as staying after closing,
forcing the waitstaff to wait for them to finish
the food they clearly despise. The entire
affair is enough to make anyone cringe.
Oh, Daphne. It was only a matter of time
before you made "Frasier" fans cringe.
Throughout the show, Niles and Daphne experience
a will-they-won't-they relationship, with Daphne
oblivious to Niles' true feelings. They finally
make things official at the end of Season 8,
which leads to Season 9's "The First Temptation
of Daphne." Still new in their relationship,
Daphne feels a tinge of jealousy and
uncertainty when Niles' new patient is
revealed to have a crush on him. Instead
of trusting Niles to treat this patient,
she goes behind his back and looks through
the patient's confidential medical file.
Not only is it cringe-inducing to witness
her insecurities and lack of boundaries,
it's genuinely shocking: What Daphne does
is a crime. We can't even say that she
learns her lesson, because after coming
clean, she faces no consequences for her
actions. Instead, she and Niles make
up, and the patient is left exploited.
A young Zooey Deschanel guest stars as
Roz's wild and opinionated cousin Jen in
Season 10's "Kissing Cousin." She embodies the
cynical 20-something with just the right amount
of cringe and attitude. Jen isn't afraid
to speak her mind, even when it comes to
disagreeing with Frasier about his beloved
Freud. Listening to her go off on tangents
about how everyone and everything is inferior
to her unique tastes is intensely cringey. Even
Roz gets sick of her constant partying and
tendency to put her down for getting old.
Everyone feels alienated by Jen's behavior —
except for a certain station manager. Kenny
feels inspired by Jen's spontaneous and
carefree view of the world. It's sweet
to see Kenny gain confidence from Jen's
words, but watching them partake in a
make-out session is significantly less
so. Clearly, this is where the episode
gets its title from. Overall, it probably
would be better off without the creepy gag.
"So, Seattle still loves the Walkman, huh?"
Frasier's AM radio show is one of
his greatest successes. He feels
good about himself when he helps the
people of Seattle with their problems,
and is constantly recognized for his stardom.
He's put up on such a high pedestal, in fact,
that when a stranger from the radio station's
focus group gives his show negative feedback in
Season 3's "The Focus Group," Frasier goes
out of his way to harass the innocent man.
Manu is a newsstand owner who
does nothing more than express
his opinion when asked for it. He simply states,
"I don't like it."
It's a fair assessment, but Frasier gets
fixated on it. He goes out of his way to
track down Manu to better understand why
he said what he said. Manu is a good guy,
and he feels betrayed by the radio station
for lying to him about the hosts listening
in. The last thing he wants to do is talk poorly
about someone else. In his search for answers,
Frasier ends up burning down Manu's
newsstand and livelihood. This lack of
empathy and narcissistic behavior makes
for a seriously cringe-worthy scene.
In the Season 5 premiere, "Frasier's Imaginary
Friend," the titular lead hits it off with
supermodel Kelly Easterbrook on a plane trip
to Mexico. During their romantic weekend,
Kelly tells him she's in the
middle of a break-up with a
professional football player
and asks him to be discreet.
Back home, Frasier unintentionally convinces
his family and co-workers that he's gone
from being lonely to delusional. When
he confides in his father, brother,
and Daphne who he's dating, they think he's lying
to avoid humiliation. It gets to the point where
his family pays a surprise visit to him in a
restaurant where he says he's meeting Kelly,
and because she has to leave dinner early for
an emergency, Niles and Marty find Frasier
eating alone and are more convinced than
ever that Kelly is as real as Santa Claus.
Rather than simply telling Kelly
about the situation and asking
if he could take a picture of them
to offer as proof — or, better yet,
just let the whole thing go — Frasier goes
down a disturbingly creepy path. One night,
Frasier waits until Kelly is sound asleep,
pulls the sheets down to reveal her shoulder,
and tries to take a selfie years before anyone
used the word. Predictably, Kelly wakes up and
once she realizes what Frasier's trying to
do, she tells him exactly what she thinks
of what he's done. Considering his behavior,
it's tough to blame her for dumping him hard.
In Season 3's "The Friend," Frasier is
disappointed to realize he's spent a few
years back in his hometown without forging
any new friendships. Against Roz's advice,
he uses his radio show to look for new buddies,
and as his producer predicts, most of the people
who respond are cringier than the show's
cringiest episodes. But amid all the refuse,
there appears to be a possible gem — Bob Reynolds,
who sends Frasier a very sane, friendly fax.
Frasier meets Bob for coffee, and at first,
things are going well. Frasier and Bob — played
by Griffin Dunne — share a love of literature.
But that's about as far as their similarities go.
Along with revealing an annoying tendency to use
air quotes often and without any rhyme or reason,
Bob spends the rest of the meetup boring
Frasier by talking about his obsession with
barbecue. Frasier is about to tell Bob
he'd rather not share dinner with him,
when Bob backs up from the table,
revealing he's in a wheelchair.
Frasier eventually breaks things off, at
first telling Bob the truth. But when Bob
says he wishes it was the wheelchair that turned
Frasier off — because that would make Frasier the
"jerk" instead of Bob — the psychiatrist
lies and says the chair is the problem,
which Bob uses to turn all the employees
and patrons of Cafe Nervosa against him.